in a factory in britain's west midlands
industrial spine this is powder coating
it applies a smooth dry finish to metal
work but to work it needs heat
so much you can see it
these ovens run at more than 200 degrees
c and that takes gas the cost of which
is about to soar threatening the
viability of this company next april we
come out of our tiding contract
and the energy bills are forecast to go
from roughly 60 to 70 000 pounds a year
to near 250 to 300 000 pounds a year
um
which at the moment is is unsustainable
keeps up at night it's like a train
coming down the tracks and then you
can't avoid it
you're constantly worried about what you
can do
wholesale gas prices aren't just fueling
the ovens here
the bank of england says they'll drive
inflation to a peak of 13.3 percent in
the autumn and will keep it above 10
until this time next year
this is imported inflation but to stop
it being baked into domestic prices the
bank's raising rates at home by the
largest amount in 28 years despite the
looming recession so is it the case this
has got to hurt if it's going to work
the reason we're doing it is because if
we don't get
the inflation under control if we don't
bring it down from where i'm afraid it's
got to go up to because of the say of
this huge energy
shock that we're having
if we don't bring it down
then then the damage and the distress
will be even greater
this is a truly bleak forecast from the
bank and its medicine will be hard for
many to swallow an interest rate rise
that could add 650 pounds to average
mortgage repayments on top of energy
bills that will rise above three and a
half thousand pounds turning energy
poverty into a mainstream issue even for
the affluent not just the very poorest
but the message from the bank is that
it's necessary to keep long-term
inflation in check
for rachel a single mother on universal
credit there's a little room left to
budget for the squeeze that lies ahead
when it first all started i'd already
you know cancelled your prime and your
netflix and things like that because you
know you've got to eat you've got to
have the heating on especially with a
two and a half year old
but i don't know how much
more i can actually cut out without
affecting
buying food in for both me and william
which is a serious
thought and
really does get me worried
this family and millions like them will
need help until the bank and government
put the lid on inflation paul kelso sky
news at the bank of england